After Watson and Crick came up with their hypothesis
regarding the structure of DNA,
the scientific world was now curious to know
how it could be replicated ?
They put forth a hypothesis that the DNA
replicates in a semiconservative manner.
That is, both strands separate and each serves
as a template for the synthesis of new strands.
Template in literal terms
means a pattern used as a sample to make something.
However, the scientific world was not ready to accept this fact easily.
So there were three theories put forth which hinted
at the replication process of the DNA double helix.
One was called the conservative model,
the other was the Dispersive model
and the last was the semiconservative model.
Let's first understand what each method had to say.
The first model in the list is the conservative model.
This model suggested that two DNA strands separate
and serve as templates for replication.
But soon after replication, the strands joined back
to form the original parent DNA,
while the new synthesised strands joined to form a completely new DNA.
Thus, we get a newly synthesised DNA molecule.
And we also get the original parent DNA molecule back, which is conserved.
Hence the name conservative replication.
Now comes the next one, this was called the Dispersive model of replication.
As the name suggests,
Dispersive means to disperse or scatter.
So what gets dispersed?
Well, according to this model the DNA which is about to replicate
breaks into small fragments.
The new strands get synthesised in between.
As a result, we get a hybrid of both new and old strands together.
The old parental strands appear to be dispersed
in the newly synthesised one.
Hence, this method is named as Dispersive.
Now comes the last model
It was called the semiconservative model of replication.
The model suggested that two strands of DNA unwind
and serve as templates for newer strands.
As a result, the replicated DNA's contained one old and one new strand.
Hence the name semiconservative.
Nevertheless, this model was not accepted initially
when put forth by Watson and Crick.
However, one of the most amazing experiments in biology
named the Meselson and Stahl experiment helped crack this mystery.
Two geneticists Matthew Meselson and Franklin Stahl
carried out an experiment around 1958.
They used a heavy isotope of nitrogen and inserted it
in the DNA of the bacterium Escherichia Coli.
They obtained several generations of E.coli and
analysed each for the presence of DNA.
The results helped them understand
that the replication of DNA in E.coli is indeed semiconservative.
This is how DNA replication takes place in almost all organisms.
Now, let me introduce you to one more interesting term.
It's called the Central Dogma.
Ever heard of this?
Well it's an important term,
and an equally interesting concept in biology.
The "Central Dogma in Molecular biology"
is used to explain the flow of genetic information.
And what does that mean?
We all know that DNA governs life.
But any idea how this mechanism works?
Let's understand this with the help of the Central dogma.
In a cell the DNA from the nucleus replicates to make a copy of itself.
This is what we're aware of
And do we know what the functional segment of DNA is?
It's a gene. It's the segment of DNA that codes for a particular character
The part of DNA which acts as a Gene
gets copied in the form of a single strand.
This is called mRNA.
This mRNA that is the messenger RNA to be precise
is a single strand copy of the DNA.
It comes out of the nucleus in the cytoplasm and then,
is worked upon by the special machinery of enzymes.
The enzyme machinery reads the code hidden in the mRNA
and synthesises proteins accordingly.
This complete process of mRNA synthesis from the DNA
followed by the synthesis of proteins from the
mRNA is called as Central dogma.
In other words this simplest process by which proteins
are synthesised from the code of the DNA molecule
is the Central Dogma of life.
This is how it's usually summarised.
Did you know that these two steps have a scientific name?
The process in which the mRNA is synthesised
from the DNA strand is called transcription.
And the process in which proteins are synthesised
from the code of mRNA is called translation.
Would you want to know more about these interesting processes?
For that, tune into our upcoming videos.